video showing the moments when police
catch a convicted murderer who had been
at large for days he escaped from the
southern desert correctional facility
near Indian Springs on Friday police
arresting him at a bus stop near Owens
and Eastern last night we have Team
coverage on this Vanessa Murphy is at
Metro Police Headquarters with a sheriff
wrapped up a news conference given us
more information about the escaped
inmates arrest but first we start with
Victoria saho she spoke to those who
first noticed the inmate and they're the
ones who call police Victoria
Brian and Denise to give you guys a
better idea of just how close door to
Herrera was to leaving the country he
was just minutes away from boarding his
10 pm shuttle bus here to Tijuana that's
when officers swarmed the bus station
after someone inside recognized him
convicted murderer Porfirio Duarte
Herrera isn't dressed like he had been
on the run for nearly five days when he
walked through the doors of Las Vegas
shuttles he like tried to avoid eye
contact and he was a little bit like
silent trying to just answer the
necessary questions Gabriel Delgadillo
manages the bus station where shuttles
to Tijuana run twice a day it was his
front desk dispatch that recognized
Duarte Herrera Wednesday night because
police were there earlier with his
picture she knew the face because the
police had already taken this flyer with
his mug shot and basically asked us to
be on the lookout what they didn't
realize is that Duarte Herrera actually
came in the day before on Tuesday
afternoon to buy his ticket video
revealing him showing an ID and paying
in cash he wanted to travel on Tuesday
and he probably couldn't because we were
already fully booked the time stamp on
the video shows Tuesday around 1 40 PM
less than an hour after Nevada
Department of Corrections announced the
inmate had escaped and later said he was
last accounted for on Friday you can see
in surveillance video Duarte Herrera
comes back Wednesday evening with gray
jeans a backpack and a hat checking in
for his bus him using some ID that was
allegedly like Father foreign ID and
looked quite new so she that made her
believe that you know he was sketchy
this is when the front desk alerted
Delgadillo who called 9-1-1 well it's
more of a risk that I don't do it Duarte
Herrera notices Police pull up he goes
to the other side of the building and
brushes past the Metro officer then just
as he was about to board onto the
shuttle he's arrested would you consider
your dispatcher a hero of course yeah we
do
now workers at this bus station say
they've been watching the news coverage
about this so they knew they needed to
be on the lookout but the name police
provided wasn't matching anyone on their
ticket list but there's still so many
questions about this where do you get
the money where do you get the clothes
we're also learning that a one-way bus
ticket from here to Tijuana cost him a
hundred and one dollars
Victoria he went through a pretty
elaborate plan to get out of prison and
and I know he's also been known to use
aliases in the past um was that at play
here when he was buying that ticket
[Music]
yeah so that general manager you just
heard from he said that when eduarte
Herrera presented his ID it said Eric
Martinez on it and that's kind of what
threw off that front desk attendant
Brian and Denise